Sarah okay you missus stunning I use a
lot of crayons are we on did we start do
you want to start again no look at you
she's barefoot and standing on a wooden
block because I'm love you so much and
I'm schvitzing like I'm like a mother
Kathy headache come say hi she is
fantastic I feel like you two could be
spirit animals like you could be best of
friends you know it I feel it I feel it
I feel it
alright I have to ask you what's in your
bag
what's in it well funny I got in trouble
a few years ago now it's legal I've got
a couple of joints taped to the top so
they don't take up space or get smushed
I have a vaild for emergencies
sunglasses real glasses because I cannot
see this is my makeup I think that your
bag is the most interesting tonight I
have my phone I got a little spritzee
yeah okay I think I love locating people
I know people always think of me as a
STONER but really I just take a puff
people absolutely nothing
oh yeah
happy about that it's so exciting right
yeah it was such a kick because we were
cancelled six months ago so we didn't
even know we were we didn't understand
that we were eligible so it was a real
kick and so I to get to come to this is
so fun and then the whole category are
our friends you know all my friends so
it's fun that's one of the fun things
about coming to these events because you
do see people that you haven't seen for
so long it's like yes as you get older
it's like a high school reunion and I
love to see the dresses oh me too it's a
section all night I think don't you yes
all night can you do
oh he's using the frame all oh my
boyfriend hi good to see you
[Music]